but dan patrick talking earlier today
about the information he's obtained
regarding the offer that was made by the
chicago bears to potentially acquire
quarterback russell wilson from the
seattle seahawks three first round picks
third round pick
and two starters
now we don't know which two starters
they're talking about once they
restructured khalil mack's contract i
assume mack was out of any package and
maybe the ship sailed on any potential
deal at that point that was a few days
ago but you know miles the problem with
three first round picks
it's where they are something peter king
pointed out yesterday the bears are at
number 20. if you're at number five or
higher it's a much more valuable pick
and if the bears have russell wilson
chances are next year the pick is going
to be 20 or lower for the bears so
three picks in that range for russell
wilson plus a third round pick plus a
couple of players that we don't even
know who they are
i can understand why the seahawks
ultimately said no thanks
oh yeah me too especially given the fact
that the bears have that pick that's a
20 this year look you can't say that
you're going to trade russell wilson and
then not have any kind of viable plan
for quarterback going forward i think if
this were a team that were in the top
five and they were to say all right
we'll give you three first round picks
then that's a little bit of a different
story because i think at least the
consensus at this point is that there
are four to five guys who could be
franchise quarterbacks that could come
in those first few picks um in the first
round so from that perspective it makes
total sense to me that seattle would say
i think we can still work things out
here with russell wilson and bears you
know you got to kick rocks and go sign
andy dalton
yeah and
the question now becomes
before we get to that before we get to
that i was on the score in chicago i do
a tuesday thing and a wednesday thing
there every week and the question came
up as to why the bears would leak this
and i'm not sure the bears
leaked it and i don't want to start
speculating on who dan sources may have
been but russell wilson was on a show
six weeks ago and that lit the fuse for
all these conversations so maybe you got
it from wilson maybe he got it from
someone close to wilson i don't know and
i don't care but from the bears
perspective
to the extent that the report from the
chicago tribune was that the bears were
going to go all in to try to get russell
wilson this isn't exactly going all in
to try to get russell wilson this is far
from herschel walker and again if you're
russell wilson you don't want to go to a
team that has given the keys to the
franchise to the seahawks in order to
get russell wilson you don't want
russell wilson to be
the the next guy in the patrick mahomes
meme from last week where it's just
wilson against 11 players on defense but
that doesn't strike me as going all in
to get russell wilson and if the bears
leaked it i don't know what they were
trying to prove by leaking it miles
well what would strike you is going all
in for wilson then i mean would it be
basically an entire draft just i'm
pushing all my chips into the middle two
drafts what do you think that would be
well remember the ricky williams trade
from 1999 back when you were probably
two the
end and i'm probably fairly close to
being accurate with that the
saints got
and get excuse me gave up an entire
draft plus another first rounder just to
move up a few spots to get ricky
williams so
look i don't know given up a full draft
i don't know what that really means by
way of value symbolically it's
significant but once you get past round
three who cares right now you're giving
up lottery tickets and you never know
when that lottery ticket is gonna end up
being a huge winner but multiple first
round picks i think four first-round
picks plus a starting quarterback like
if the jets would show up with
the two picks this year the two picks
next year
and sam darnold because the jets hold
seattle's first round picks in 2021 and
22 from the jamal adams trade that would
to me be wow wow but the bears don't
have the ability to do that i think you
have to yeah and and
yeah i just don't think the bears can
get there from where they start khalil
mack would have had to have been part of
it the three first round picks maybe
three second round picks to get to the
point where you get the seahawks
attention and make it worth their while
especially because of the fact again
that they're at number 20 this year and
chances are they're going to be at 20 or
lower in future years if they have
russell wilson so i just don't think the
bears were ever going to be able
to do it
and i don't know that that it benefits
them to put out there what they
ultimately offered especially the day
after they agreed to terms with andy
dalton i tend to think this comes from
wilson's camp and it's aimed at sending
a message to one of these other teams
because i do think i do think miles even
though
mark rogers the agent for russell wilson
identified only the bears cowboy saints
raiders i think there's other teams he's
got in his pocket that russell wilson
would take a trade to
and maybe this was just aimed at at
pulling the cord on the lawnmower to see
if one of these other teams will get it
done whether it's the panthers with the
eighth pick the dolphins with the third
pick or the jets with the second pick
well i think that there has to be some
other contingency plan with these other
teams right because at this point you
know the four teams that were on that
list the raiders the cowboys the bears
and the lasting the saints
all of those guys seem to at least have
some sort of quarterback solution in
place with perhaps the exception of the
raiders where i think if they really
wanted to get something done then maybe
they could try and at least they would
have derek carr to send back uh to
seattle and he's a viable quarterback
and you know maybe that those uh picks
that would ostensibly be in the 20s or
lower
then you'd be okay as long as you have
that qb already in place so that's
something where
if russell wilson really wants to get
out and you know the raiders say we
really want this guy to be our qb then
maybe that could make it work but i
think you're right to bring up get
somebody like the panthers too because
they seem very hell-bent on getting a
franchise quarterback this offseason and
obviously the reports today have been
that they are singularly focused on
getting to sean watson but i think if
you know russell wilson were to become
available to them especially because
scott federer came from seattle
organization that's not something that
they would turn their nose up at because
obviously russell wilson has been so
consistent for so long mike that yeah he
he is somebody that should be a
franchise quarterback and that anybody
should probably want if they don't have
one already
i'm fascinated by the possibility that
scott fitter doesn't want russell wilson
because he knows what he's buying
with russell wilson because he's been in
seattle and he knows what russell wants
both from a football standpoint and from
a financial standpoint russell wilson
likes to break the bank every chance he
gets that's one of the benefits of
having an agent who has only one client
i've said this before mark rogers is not
burdened by the realities of broader
relationships with general managers for
other clients because if you reach for
too much with one guy
you potentially piss people off who
otherwise can give some of your other
guys jobs pick this guy over that guy
you get an opportunity we have a good
relationship with you so we're going to
give you a break here you took care of
us on this we're going to help you out
that's how the sausage gets made mark
rogers doesn't have to play that game
because russell wilson's his only client
and fitter may be thinking i don't have
to negotiate with mark rogers because
when you trade a player you're getting
the player you're getting everything
you're inheriting whatever problems the
seahawks have and if you're not going to
solve the problems the seahawks have
with wilson
they're your problems now and you got
them under contract for three more years
and regardless of whether or not he's
happy with his role and his influence
and the offense running through him
regardless of all of that he's going to
want 45 million a year or whatever the
top of the market is
when 2023 rolls around so that may be
one of the reasons why when we hear the
reports about the panthers and deshawn
watson it's just deshawn watson and not
russell wilson
well that's a good point and i think the
other part of that is when you say that
mark rogers only has that one client
that's probably why he's more
comfortable going on the record and
saying as russell wilson's agent here
are the four teams that this guy would
be interested in going to because he's
not as concerned about the other clients
that could possibly be on those other
teams i mean look when you're talking
about the raiders and russell wilson
being interested in going to the raiders
derek carr is already there you know
derek carr has helped lead a team to the
playoffs already and albeit that was in
2016 but it's not like derek carr is not
an established quarterback for las vegas
so i think that that encapsulates so
much of what's going on with this
russell wilson situation because
he as russell wilson is the quarterback
he wants a certain amount of power he
wants his offensive line to get better
he wants to make sure that he has some
sort of influence over what the scheme
is going to be
and
it remains to be seen if when they
actually give him the keys
that he can really consistently
be it often the type of offensive threat
that you would expect a quarterback who
has that much power to be
yeah i agree with you completely and
you've got to be ready to make him your
patrick mahomes that's what he's looking
for
and if someone doesn't make the seahawks
an offer they won't refuse
the seahawks have to figure out a way to
to focus on getting the most out of this
year now look russell wilson supposedly
can compartmentalize and he'll deal with
it and he'll stay in seattle and make
the most of it but it doesn't mean he's
as happy as he can be and it doesn't
mean he's going to stay there long term
and i heard not long after he signed his
last contract in seattle that this is
his last contract in
seattle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports